[Music]
homie look what I become
okay our guest today Tina glandian from
uh she's a partner at law firm uh uh
garrigus and garages have to think about
asparagus garrigus and garagus and she's
been a former lawyer to celebrities such
such as Mike Tyson Chris Brown Michael
Jackson Keisha as well as Jesse Smollett
and now Andrew Tay Tina thank you so
much for making the time
thanks for having me yeah so you know
we've been following the story very
closely some of the audience that's here
let's assume they don't know and they
haven't seen the other interviews you've
done with other folks we have followed
it closely but just to uh uh start off
with an open-ended question how are they
doing right now how are Andrew and
Tristan doing right now
so I spoke to Andrew yesterday
um and you know they're obviously beyond
frustrated at the situation however one
of the things that I think wasn't as
widely covered as the fact that their
detention was ordered continued for
another 30 days uh is the fact that the
two women that they that they were
detained with and who've been in custody
since the end of December alongside them
they were released under house arrest so
they are now home and that was obviously
in our opinion a big step in the right
direction and when I spoke to Andrew
when I was trying to see how they're
feeling after that result because you
know two of the four got sent home under
house arrest his reaction was that if he
had a choice and if he could decide
which two of the four would get to go
home he would have had the women go home
because he said obviously jail is a
really rough place and he thought it was
better that he and his brother suffer if
anybody has to rather than the women
kudos to him for doing that now here's a
question for you are you representing
all four or just the brothers
just the brothers okay so now are you in
their legal team working closely
together is it a team or is it
separately
no definitely I'm working alongside the
Romanian legal defense team because
again I'm not a Romanian attorney I
can't appear before the Court's there I
attended the previous hearing and I was
able to observe and be in the courtroom
you know at the table with my Romanian
Council but I can't actually address the
judges in Romania so I'm working very
closely with them we're in constant
communication and we are handling the
defense together got it so so the the
two girls I believe Georgina and Luana
if I'm saying it correctly right
Georgina and Lana
Georgina's known Tate for quite some
time Luana was a former police officer
and they were uh friends and Associates
working together my question is are
there lawyers and you working together
are you guys on the same team
um we're not necessarily working
together however everybody pretty much
has a consistent defense which is nobody
committed any crimes in this case got it
so to that extent everyone has a common
goal and interest in this case however
uh you know we're not necessarily
working together okay and the only
reason I asked this and so please push
back anything I ask in skepticism
whatever I say you know I'm just
thinking like a uh I've interviewed a
lot of people that are in different
lives they've lived you know I've
interviewed the Sammy the Bulls of the
world a lot of former mobsters and the
model the government will sometimes use
when they have multiple uh folks that
they're working on they'll try to go to
the weak ones to get information out of
them and try to get a deal and say hey
if you tell us this it's going to be
this do you want to be in jail for the
put the fear attack you know the tactics
they use this is your world so how
confident are you that for the folks
that are worried if they will keep the
four fully fully United on the same page
versus the government's going to try to
get the girls to break and say something
so some may look at this as a hey
they're now being released to go home
this could be seen as did they do a deal
with the government or it's Andrew and
Tristan saying no if anyone's going to
go home they're going to go home
so two different things first of all I
think absolutely it's a common both a
police and prosecution strategy to try
to divide and conquer I think
um how we refer to it here is they
always try to get the weakest link to
roll on you know the bigger Target so
absolutely I would not be surprised if
that's something that the prosecution
intends or tries to do however we feel
confident that there's nothing for these
girls you know short of if they were to
decide to come forward and lie beyond
that we're not afraid of anything they
would say and we're not afraid of them
of the police or prosecution exerting
pressure because we think again the
truth is going to set everybody free
including the tape Brothers yeah that's
my biggest concern my biggest concern is
them trying to gamify it and they try
not listen uh Art of War Sun Tzu divide
and conquer put them against each other
put the fear tactic and then eventually
get him to open up and give them
protection for a couple years and you
get the information can you release
other people that we can get so that's
why I ask are you guys working
collectively together or not okay so
that was helpful if you have a response
sure if I could just interrupt for one
second I was gonna say there's also in
this case voluminous
um what we call documentary evidence
meaning text messages written
correspondence and we think that speaks
for itself and when again unfortunately
I can't get into the details with you
now the way I wish I could go through
specific evidence and show why you know
this case immediately falls apart but we
think even
in the worst case scenario if somehow
the prosecution got to the girls and got
them to change their story and not be
truthful you know in exchange for some
sort of deal to get them uh out of this
we think that the documentary evidence
will undercut any you know potential
argument that the Tate brothers are
guilty of any of the charges that
they're being investigated for when you
speak to Tate and I don't know if you're
going to answer this or not is that a
concern that the two girls may do
something because if I'm an attorney I'm
going to ask the question you can say no
to all the answers but I'm just going to
do my job as a person asking questions
if I'm the attorney I want to know
everything about those two girls what
they have on you what would they say how
would they come back what would be their
weak spot is there anything that you're
worried about and then we're not worried
about it we are worried about it is that
a potential concern at all or no that is
the last thing we're concerned about
right now that is the last thing we're
concerned about we believe everybody is
just trying to get the truth out and all
four of them are again they have the
same common interest in doing that when
it's going to set all of them free yeah
my fear is government I don't trust what
they do to pin people against each other
so we'll see what they're going to be
doing so okay
um the next question for me would be
with the following you you're you have a
track record you're very successful the
audience doesn't know this you and I
went to high school together and we've
never met but uh you know just figure
that out minutes before the interview
literally just figure this out minutes
uh before the interview yes which was
interesting that's when I looked at your
last name I said that's an Armenian
lesson and they say no you don't say
nalbandian it's now bendian I'm like oh
okay let me find that for myself and
then we figure that out but you know the
cases you've worked out these are not
small cases these are heavyweight cases
uh you know uh whether it's Michael
Jackson whether it's Justin that was
very controversial whether it's you know
the other ones Brown norquisha all of
these things we can go through how
different of a jurisdiction I am not a
lawyer how different is it uh dealing
with the laws that we go by in the
states let alone dealing with somebody
that you're representing who's in
Romania do you have to are you are you
working with their laws do they kind of
push you around do you hold them
accountable to you because there is the
U.S citizenship how to do those Dynamics
work
sure so I think typically in high
profile cases already there are so many
additional factors that go into
representing a client that isn't there
in a standard case when the attorneys
actually just get to focus on their
defense on the legal strategy and it's
very clear cut and typically in those
cases the defendants also really are
Presumed Innocent so those cases are
much easier to handle
the high profile cases to begin with
Once information is and it's almost
exclusively leaked by the prosecution or
the police the information comes out
it's always out of context the defense
can't really respond to it as far as to
address the details but because there's
an ongoing investigation you're not
supposed to be
talking about those facts so you're
really at a disadvantage and the public
starts getting a false picture of what
the case is about what the evidence is
and so you know already in a high
profile case you're dealing with the
court of public opinion everything
that's coming out combating the
misinformation that's circulating and so
those are challenges now you add to that
you know all of this happening in a
foreign jurisdiction and yes it makes it
much more complicated there's you know
difficulties like for now I have not
actually been able to visit the Tate
Brothers in jail while I was in
Bucharest I went numerous times to the
jail with my Romanian colleagues we took
all the paperwork and I was told that
it's ultimately the prosecutor's
decision and the prosecutor until now
still hasn't approved the request I mean
we're still trying and hopefully I will
um get to see them of course my
preference would be to see them out of
custody but depending on the timing
however
um you know it's it's difficult to
you're in a different time zone all of
the documents are in the Romanian
language so we have to have everything
translated or I'm relying on my Romanian
Council to interpret things for me their
system is different so it's you know and
the politics of it are different so it's
certainly very challenging
is that a protocol that the prosecutor
can use according to the Romanian laws
to not allow you to meet with your
client I mean is that a common thing
they do there or do you have a leverage
to say no I have to see my client this
is how the laws work
so unfortunately I don't think it's very
common for U.S attorneys or I should say
even attorneys who are not Romanian to
be trying to visit Romanian clients in
jail so it's not a common occurrence to
begin with and according to my Romanian
Council they say it's this is how it
works it's standard now if this was not
the Tate brothers would this have been
approved by now
I'm not sure do uh does does the role of
uh well I'll come back to that so I
guess my other question would be when
you were working with Jesse and he was
being accused or you know the the things
that we he was going through with what
happened to him I believe he was still
he was not in jail when he was going
through it right I know the detention
and I may be wrong the detention here
this is the third round of 30 days and
they can go up to 180 days but they're
still we still don't know fully what is
going on the key word that's being used
is allegedly allegedly allegedly of
human trafficking allegedly of this once
again is this a uh uh a common thing
that that Romania does as a government
to say whether we have you or not you
got to be in here mostly some of the
times people don't know they live around
the world American laws are different
than Romanian laws are different than
German or UK so it's to understand how
these things work so the whole 180 days
that they have we keep extending it at
this pace what are some of the criterias
that you can use to get them to be at
least at home while they're going
through this
so yes this is
for us because this is not how our
system works here in the U
typically in it it varies a little bit
by jurisdiction but typically they have
48 hours to you know hold you but before
they either have to charge you or
release you Romania has a different
procedure and they refer to it as
preventative arrest where they they
initially held held the tape Brothers
for 24 hours and then they applied for a
30-day extension and as you correctly
said they can extend that up to
180 days so
this period is actually still an ongoing
criminal investigation so they have not
actually had an indictment returned
against them they have not been formally
charged and again this is really
contrary to our Notions of Justice which
is that you know pre-trial deprivation
is really to be a measure of Last Resort
unless there's substantial factors
warranting keeping somebody in in
custody that they should be out and when
you said allegedly allegedly is a word
that you use even you know after the
charges are filed here we're not even
there yet we're still in an open
criminal investigation and so if that
answers your question I think the
process is very different in Romania
than we're used to here in the US and I
think a lot of other places how are you
as the attorney adapting to that I mean
are you uh uh I bet this is a tough job
you have I mean you went to school here
you went to grade school you've done
phenomenal for yourself so to learning
how to work with the laws here to
represent your client and then to go
over there are you like on a overdrive
of learning all the laws and you're
reading this and that to see what the
adjustments are you're looking at all
the cases is that kind of what you're
going through as an individual
definitely I'm doing a lot of research
on how the Romanian process works
reading some of their cases and some
decisions even by the European courts as
to how they've applied Romanian law and
whether they've sanctioned um this type
of conduct I'm of course talking to my
Romanian colleagues who are the best
source of information as to what is
common there so there's a lot to take in
but obviously you know when you asked
how I'm dealing with it for me it's much
easier to deal with as the attorney on
the outside it's much harder to see my
clients who are in jail and it makes my
job a lot harder when I can't easily
communicate with them so that's the
biggest I think Factor here is the fact
that I wasn't I would have stayed in
Bucharest had I been granted access to
visit with them uh frequently but that's
been the the biggest challenge for me so
far if that happened in America you
could make calls to get Congress or
somebody a senator or Congressman or
congresswoman to make the call and say
what is this all about you can't be
doing this right so who can you call
because the the part that makes it
complicated with this if you have a
political figure let's just say you have
a political figure and if they're a
Democrat the president's Democrat well
you make the phone call Hey listen this
is a you know if you have a republican
Trump saying hey Roger Stone hey you got
this can you what is going on over can
you guys make the call this doesn't make
any sense who can you call to say this
is not a fair thing they're doing
I mean who I did call when I was in
Bucharest was the U.S embassy to see if
I could get assistance with this but
they they pretty much just deferred me
to my Romanian Council and said I have
to work with them and follow the
procedure that they recommend so
ultimately they weren't really much help
in me trying to achieve that how much of
that do you think uh is because him
being a controversial figure and he's
called that pretty much everybody Under
the Sun you know they tell you there's
three things you should never talk about
two of them are politics and religion
and as a my mother would always say hey
Patrick why are you talking politics
I've told you for years never talk
politics just talk business why are you
the fear right he's called out everybody
so how much of that has to be with uh
him calling out the people in power
they're like if there's anybody we're
not helping we are definitely not
helping Tate
you know I would be guessing but I
certainly would think in a case that
didn't involve maybe Andrew Tate that
the U.S embassy would have been more
helpful when it involved a U.S citizen
yeah that's just I would probably give
the answer as well if I was in your
situation but for me and many other
people that are listening they would be
uh uh uh thinking maybe there's some of
that going on as well let me transition
I got the WhatsApp messages I want to
get to a part of that as well with the
messages that came out but uh the other
question I would have for you is
with them saying hey uh now that these
messages have come out you know we are
thinking we are gonna I'm gonna be suing
him for 300 million dollars I'm sure you
saw that tweet that came out I saw your
answer on this but some of the audience
may not know about it are they actively
personally do they have access to the
internet are they Tweeting or is all the
tweets that are coming out or the
messages or the email that's coming out
it's somebody else emailing tweeting on
behalf of Tates
it's not yes they don't have access to
Twitter or social media so they're
they're in a jail cell with a very
limited access to just phone calls that
are all recorded they don't have access
uh to social media so yes they're not
they're not posting anything themselves
got it you said phone calls that are all
recorded So whoever they have a call
with it's all recorded
yes
and and so
so even if you want to talk to your
client
they're recording all the calls you're
having with your client
yes so as I said it's very challenging
to oh God not be able to visit the
client in person and to be
you know having limited Communications
which of course
um you know are recorded phone calls
how do you strategize how do you uh how
do you
how do you say Hey you know because you
need intel so who do you get Intel from
to be able to defend there's only so
much you're gonna get if you can't have
a and you can't ask the question if you
know it's going to be recorded because
who do you trust if you know the calls
are being recorded you almost can't
trust having any conversations with them
because you know it's all going to leak
to somebody how do you manage that
we we're aware of the fact that the
calls are recorded as are the clients of
course
um and you know at this point the
strategy really is just for us to try to
get to the truth and how do we find the
truth so it's it's obviously limiting
but and you know we keep the
conversations short and discuss what we
need to but it poses certainly a big
challenge Tina is that also the case in
America so if if you want to talk to a
client of yours and you're going to go
and have a conversation with them is is
it a hundred percent recorded you have
to assume that everybody else can hear
the conversation or are you able to have
one-on-one combo with your client
without anybody hearing it
so typically jail calls are always
recorded now when it's an attorney call
and you announce that at the beginning
of the call and you say this is Tina
glandian and this is an attorney client
phone conversation they're either
supposed to stop the recording or later
if if it was you know automatically
recorded they are not to listen to
anything that's attorney clients so even
if that gets bypassed in some cases they
can't use it because they're not allowed
to record the attorney client's
Communications but it's it's it's not
it's not unusual because calls are also
recorded here however when you get to
visit in person in an attorney-client
context you should be in a setting
that's not recorded do you do you trust
it in America like does it is it even a
thought like do you guys as a group sit
there and say listen ask the question
but make sure it's not all the questions
just be aware that somebody could be
listening to it or is it a code where
it's like no talk freely as long as you
say it's a lawyer you don't have
anything to worry about
no we're always a little bit cautious
because again rules get broken and just
because someone's not supposed to do
something doesn't mean it won't happen
so we are cautious in all cases sure so
you know during covid uh uh uh I've I've
run an insurance company I've been to
financial industry for 20 years so
you're dealing with lawyers all the time
I've spent a lot of money on lawyers so
we've we've kept a lot of law firms in
business because you have to deal with
it but during covet when we were dealing
with lawyers or courts everything was
super slow and I'm talking hey things
that would get done in 30 60 90 days
nine you know nine months to 12 months
to get anything they're not coming in
they're not doing this they're not doing
that and it was very annoying because
you couldn't get things to be resolved
quickly are you dealing with any other
factors that is delaying uh you being
able to get to the bottom of what's
going on there was it just purely the
government saying hey this is how slow
we're working we can take our time if we
want to and there's nothing we can do
about it
with their procedure with their
preventative arrest procedure that they
have in place they certainly you know
have the protection that they could
extend this to 180 days and there really
isn't much we can do if they continue to
try to take the position that they
shouldn't be released because you know
they might be a flight risk or they're a
potential danger and things of that
nature so
um I do find normally that in high
profile cases that because there are so
many eyes on a Case typically those tend
to move a bit faster than maybe a normal
case wood that gets put on the back
burner and nobody's in a rush to
prosecute that
so typically they do move a little
faster now in this case this has been an
extremely slow investigation so I know
they've been in custody since the end of
December but what a lot of people might
not recognize is this investigation
actually started in April of 2022 and
there was allegations made at the time
you know police did a raid they
investigated and there was nothing to
those allegations so but they did open
up you know a bigger investigation and
another fact because you did bring up
the 300 million dollar
um you made some reference to a
potential lawsuit about that and so just
to make this clear what happened is
after this investigation happened in
April and it was shown that
um the allegations were false and the
police you know made no arrests at the
time the tape Brothers actually filed
criminal complaints in Romania against
the two women who made these accusations
and again that's not a fact that's been
widely reported but that is an open
criminal investigation against the women
and that started you know almost eight
months before the Tate brothers were
ever arrested or you know investigated
really for any of the criminal
accusations that they're currently being
investigated for so the lawsuit that you
referenced and the cease and desist
letter that is part of that original
criminal complaint that was initiated in
April by the brothers when they were not
charged or being investigated for
anything further and when they were the
victims of false allegations and they
were pursuing their legal rights
and that was in April so from April till
February now but they put him in jail uh
you know the timing of that to me
there's there's a lot of theories out
there and I'll just pose the question
you know you you're a pro you're going
to give whatever response you're gonna
give
sometimes you know certain events happen
you know it could be ironic it could be
like coincidental or it could be like ah
you know it's a little bit this you kind
of cross the line with who you went
after with the Greta thundberg and all
this other stuff and here's what you did
in booming and all of a sudden two days
could they have done what they did to
the Tate Brothers what they did two days
after Greta could they have done the
same exact thing and started detention
in April in May in June uh you know what
I'm saying like could it have just
automatically said hey why not wait till
this time it just so happens they did it
two days after that so there's some
theories where maybe he crossed the line
a little bit you're pushing a little bit
too much of the envelope and this is
attempt to take this guy down and
silence him
so I guess to break it down a little bit
what they were initially the allegations
that were made in April were that these
women were being held against their will
by the Tate brothers and that was
investigated and that there was
absolutely no truth to that so they were
they were not you know their status when
the investigation started of the Tate
brothers were as Witnesses and so
Romania has different categories that
they put people in you could either be a
witness a suspect or a defendant so they
started in April they were witnesses to
this allegation the police investigated
there was nothing there and that's what
the criminal complaints that they filed
in April were about you know those
particular instances now since that time
I think you know police began to to
surveil the brothers and were I think
trying to find something to further
investigate
um and again I don't want to speculate
as to the reasons why they were trying
to you know find
further further you know allegations to
investigate
um but the timing of it yes it's
obviously it was many many months later
what may have triggered that particular
uh date it's hard to say so so in other
words they could have done that earlier
right so they could have because if it's
allegedly human trafficking rape they
could have done it in August they could
have done it in July they could have
done it in June they just so happened to
choose to do it two days after that and
I know that whole one thing where people
were like well if you're going to order
pizza why would you put the pizza that
was already debunked and that's not even
a part of the conversation if they
wanted to get them they're going to get
them it's not like they're going places
they're not going avoiding places this
is specific about the fact that could
the government have
come in and taking them to jail and put
them in detention in any other month
except the time that they did it at
yes because again this is preventative
arrest it's not like they had you know
enough evidence to charge them with
crimes this was a preventative arrest
because they were investigating they
certainly could have done this you know
weeks earlier if that's what they chose
to do so so what that does is that gives
a lot of credence to the audience that
is saying this guy's being set up
because of who he called out and the
establishment to that audience that goes
I told you so I knew this I know well
you're giving them credit if you're
doing it this way so I I almost think
um I almost think that works against
them and it works in your favor why are
you waiting this long until you're doing
XYZ okay so let's go to the next one and
then I got a couple other things here as
well so if if there's anybody that has
lived a life where
they've lived a very interesting life I
don't think anybody can you know dispute
that you know however many cars you got
all the the women the travel the
lifestyle the Yachts to this the that
the fighting
it's like the profile of a guy where a
16 year old boy is going to look up and
go man look at this guy he's a tough guy
he knows how to fight against the girl
sees this he's out I'm gonna be like
this guy I think the moment Tate started
wearing glasses I'd never seen a spike
in more YouTubers wearing glasses when
they're doing interviews in the middle
of the day and that never happened until
this guy was wearing glasses right he
made them look good but mentally and
emotionally tough the life they've lived
the father they've had the experiences
they've had it's it's it's almost like
that's preparing you that if you do go
through something like this they can't
break you they're going to try to break
you how are they holding up purely
mentally and emotionally uh uh
themselves I I'm sure knowing him how
competitive he is and how annoyed he is
and how much he likes to be in control
like a lot of business CEOs we
understand that DNA and the fabric of
wanting to be in control and now you're
not so there's a part that's driving him
and saying but also you see him when
he's walking on he's always got the
Quran in his hand and so I'm assuming
he's praying a lot so he's trying to
work on his how how when you talk to
them how are you feeling their energy
they're they're where they're at
you know the the energy is remarkably
positive in light of where they're at
and what they're going through I think
they just have tremendous resolve and
strength and that's both mental and
physical and emotional strength so I
think they're doing the best they can in
the situation they're in to stay
physically strong I know they're you
know continuing to exercise and work out
and do what they can within the confines
of being in jail but to stay physically
strong at the same time as you said they
are praying meditating
um they receive a lot of letters and you
know fan mail so they they read those it
keeps them you know occupied so they are
the one you know they don't complain
about boredom it's more about just this
intense frustration of having all of
this going on you're you know
proclaiming your innocence you want to
prove your innocence and you are in a
jail cell where you can't you have no
means to do so so you know you're
putting a lot of trust obviously in your
team and your attorneys
but but it's very frustrating to be in
that situation I think again under the
circumstances
um I think they are holding up quite
well even though it's very challenging
I I bet but but again I think if there's
anybody that could do this the two of
the guys together you know we one time I
think Tate said you can take everything
away from me as long as you don't take
my brother I'm gonna be okay you know to
do the way the father raised to get
these two guys to be as close as they
are that's probably giving them a lot of
strength are they in the same seller are
they keeping them separate where they
can't interact with each other or be
around each other
uh I I know that they they do interact
um I'm not I'm not actually quite
certain about the cell situation because
I think that's changed you know over
over the detention period got it so you
know this other question here
if if back in the days when they went
after Capone or uh I've spent a lot of
time with Rudy Giuliani you know who he
is how he cleaned the streets in New
York the other day we're at an Italian
restaurant here in uh Florida we're
having lunch with uh you know a couple
folks Rudy is there the owner of the
restaurant comes in and says oh my god
when I lived in New York to clean up the
streets he automatically went to when I
was in New York to clean up the streets
and how he was able to work with
changing the laws to you know figure out
a way to how to go get them and even
back in the days they didn't get Capone
on anything but on taxes so there's
there's many ways if the government
really wants to Target somebody to ruin
their lives
you got a lot of cards to use right you
can do well let's use rape allegation
it's not hard to do there's a lot of
people that have been there that never
committed a crime but you know you kind
of have to you know prove your argument
hey let's do trafficking hey let's do
taxes hey let's do this
do you think this is going to be one of
those things that if they really want to
Target these guys they're going to keep
using their cards until they get them or
is this truly their only focus on these
two allegations that they're making
no I think you raise a really good point
and I think that's exactly what's going
on in this case I think that's why this
investigation initially started in April
They seized you know a lot of their
belongings devices things like that and
I think it's just been this a very
lengthy search for any evidence of crime
and I think as far as the actual charges
that are being investigated I think
those are going to be proven
demonstrably false I think
everything we've seen shows that the
prosecution it's it's such a stretch
they're trying to pigeonhole
um human trafficking into a set of facts
that just it doesn't fit
and
um again the rape allegation is entirely
unsupported I think the evidence which
again unfortunately at this point in the
proceedings I just can't comment on but
I think there's damning evidence uh
showing that these are not
charges that would ever be proven so I
think the fear is and also one other
fact is you know the other allegation is
of an organized criminal uh organized
crime Group which includes the two women
who were just released on house arrest
which I think again is a big um I guess
it speaks a lot as to what the evidence
is that during this investigation now
they've released the women on house
arrest the same women that are allegedly
part of this organized criminal group so
I do not feel that they're they're ever
going to be able to prove any of the
charges that are currently being
investigated I just think they're using
these this preventative arrest to
prolong their detention in hopes of
actually being able to find evidence of
crime which they don't currently have
yeah that's going to be the interesting
part because if they do that you know
it's targeting you know it's targeting
is there anybody that if
uh for example
um you know uh uh I keep going political
because Tate is political and and that's
where you can do all the other stuff
it's one thing but he calls out a lot of
people that are not liking the call-outs
that he makes
so if when Trump's running and they had
their RNC who they wanted to be at the
RNC well Dana White spoke and he says
look I don't this is all I know about
the guy 20 years ago when nobody gave us
a place to go and do our first event for
UFC he said yes I'm gonna back this guy
up because Vegas said no this said and
he said yes and he helped us stay in
business okay so that gets the audience
of UFC to say man shoot if Dana's
defending Trump maybe I ought to right
hey Barack Obama hey I'm Oprah Winfrey
listen this is the guy we've been
looking for we've been looking okay boom
support you know what if Oprah says it
you know I got to kind of support this
hey the other day Oprah hey I as much as
I'm the one that found Dr Oz I'm not
going to go against Dr Oz uh for Dr Oz
I'm going to go for fetterman I think
fetterman's better people like wait a
minute that's your guy but you're going
there's a lot of weight in who supports
who and says what right politically
um how much like is there any other
because ever since you know he he spoke
about his Muslim religion and videos
were posted about him going out there
and praying uh and you know how he feels
about the westernized you know
Christianity the the standards all of
that is there support from a sect or a
community that has reached out to say
Tina how can we help we would like to
get involved to help is there anything
like that taking place or is it silence
no one's saying anything they're just
kind of saying well let's see what
happens here we're going to keep our
hands off of this
there are there are many many
um efforts by people who want to help it
hasn't really come from some sort of
organized sect of you know of anything
like that but we have so many
individuals reaching out offering
support and help and you know I think
it's a little tricky in cases like this
where it is political as you said and
people are outside like the Tates are
very outspoken particularly Andrew I
think
sometimes there is you know reluctance
from people to publicly show support and
to come out when when they still do
support the individuals so I experienced
this in Jessie's case where he had a lot
of support a lot of people who had
privately message him I believe in you I
believe you but those same people felt
that in this climate they couldn't come
forward and publicly support him because
of the tremendous backlash because again
there was this false narrative and based
on the information that was put forward
by you know the one-sided leaks and
everything else people believed a
different set of facts than what the you
know actual facts were and based on that
they didn't want to come out and support
somebody who who may have done what
people were saying he did so I think
there's a lot of that in this case too
where they're certainly certainly is a
lot of private support
now who would be willing to come forward
publicly I'm not sure because I think
there is a lot of backlash
I bet I bet there is uh uh but maybe
some need to see this and hear this to
say hey we're going to come out and
support maybe they need to hear this
message and say hey let's make a phone
call and offer what we can I don't know
what happens when they're freezing uh
freezing accounts cars taking stuff that
you know there's many ways I interviewed
F Lee Bailey nine years ago 10 years ago
and they took his license away as well
and you know F Lee Bailey wrote one of
the best books ever for lawyers you know
which one I'm talking was like two
thousand Pages examination right the
legendary book that everybody talks
about which I haven't read because I'm
not a lawyer but I know you know which
book I'm talking about so and they took
his license that's one way where when
you're a lawyer for too long and you
represent a lot of people and then you
keep doing it and you're allowed
sometimes the way they do it is hey take
this guy's license away he can make
money and then that's how they go broke
it's a sad situation on what they do but
in this instance you know if they're
freezing accounts if they're freezing
everything you know are are you know
maybe this is a way and I don't know
financial situation where that are they
able to make the payments to you you're
not a cheap lawyer you're not somebody
that's 400 bucks an hour that's a very
expensive lawyer you are so if
somebody's hiring someone like you are
they able to meet their expenses that
they're you know having to pay today is
that something that they're able to do
are they Frozen right now with their
funds
so they've seized a lot of assets
have seized you know a great amount of
assets which is vastly disproportionate
to any sort of money that the government
would need as a result of this
investigation so it is concerning all
the assets they've taken and this you
know really comes back to
why you know they are in this prolonged
detention all of these things are being
seized that's putting a lot of pressure
um I don't know if it's in the hopes
that at some point they crack and
confess to something they didn't do but
that's not going to happen so
yeah I was watching an interview the
other day with musk where musk is like
he called out the SEC I don't know if
you've seen this clip or not he says you
know he says what he says to the SEC and
he says they call me and they said you
have to do this or else this or else
that or else this and he says I agree
but let me tell you something you know
he took a shot at SCC right afterwards
in the interview and it's a public video
going viral where it's like hey you need
to come out and say yes you did this or
you need to come on and say you did that
it'll be interesting to see like you're
saying they're not going to break that
these guys don't seem like the kind that
they're going to be break but I wonder
the government people think they're so
creative until you go into you know you
think criminals are the most creative
people let you know people are a lot
more creative uh in the government than
they know because they see all these
cases so they know how to maneuver what
power that nobody else can you can't go
write a negative view about the
government on Yelp oh my God we gotta
know you can't do that that's only in
the free markets that we experienced
that so the next thing I want to talk
about is WhatsApp messages that came out
when you saw this this was live a lot of
people reacted to it a lot of people
read them a lot of people looked oh my
God this is it it's over it's going to
be done you can be doing something like
this what was your reaction when you
first saw these WhatsApp messages of
these two girls going back and forth you
know we got them do this I can't never
played the victim all these things we've
all read them what was your reaction
when you saw this that was to the public
is this a benefit benefit for Tate that
shows what they're doing or was it kind
of like yeah we're not even going to be
using this
so unfortunately I'm really limited to
addressing uh you know potential
evidence in the case and so I cannot
address that at this time and I wish I
could
um but that's for a later discussion for
now I have to be very careful about what
I say as to matters that are still being
investigated fair enough if if the
people haven't seen it uh Rob let's put
a link below uh where they can go read
it for themselves The Exchange when you
look at this it definitely looks like
and I know you can't comment on this I'm
just telling the audience for them to it
definitely looks like they are uh uh
framing that's it they are playing the
game they are talking to each other play
dumb good advice thank you babe you know
all these weird things play the victim I
mean we are like uh act like we still
love them and stuff blah blah blah all
these things tomorrow we should wear
makeup and sunglasses so nobody really
notices yeah I guess LOL we should make
a movie out of this so when you see this
you you know I've seen the the both
sides of the argument on these tweets on
these uh exchanges what people are
saying that are saying well they're
innocent and I see the side where people
are saying well they're guilty they can
make up uh their mind for themselves but
this definitely tells a lot here so uh
last but not least Tina before we wrap
up and once again thank you so much for
you being generous with your time I know
you're working a lot of things and
you're probably not getting a lot of
sleep because you're working with time
zones when we were uh uh going through
doing a deal and at the time we were in
France and we were selling one of our
companies and the people that we were
doing business with were in San
Francisco that time zone messed us up we
try to have a good time but we were
non-stop you know doing this and we're
trying to entertain people it's kind of
weird place so I appreciate you for
being patient with your time to wrap up
here any any final thoughts on where you
are with this your level of optimism you
know just a couple weeks ago tweet came
out oh my God they're going to be free
today oh this thing's a every day
someone's saying they're gonna be free
today they're going to be free today
what were you you are today what is your
level of optimism of how this thing's
going to end
I have a great deal of optimism in where
this will end as far as what's currently
being investigated because again there
have been what's really important in all
this time that's passed there has been
no new evidence no new alleged victims
nothing new to support this case and
clearly at this point the evidence has
not been strong enough for them to file
charges against the brothers so I think
they're going to push this preventative
arrest you know because they can for now
while they're looking for evidence but
um everything I've seen I think it is
not going to be hard to disprove all of
these uh allegations so I'm I'm very
optimistic in the ultimate result of
this case obviously it's not as soon as
we would like we
um each day they're in custody we feel
like it's an injustice because they
should be home but the only other thing
I want to add is that
you know you hear human trafficking and
that sounds awful but this is
this is just not a case of human
trafficking and again without getting
into the evidence obviously it's
difficult to explain really what I mean
but this you know to emphasize the
webcam business is a legitimate business
in Romania many women have come forward
there's articles you can read about how
about why this is such a thriving
business there and this gives women
there a means of making a lot more
income
um you know some of the time women don't
have the means or the education to make
the kind of money that they could get
from an industry like this and you know
their standard like any other job they
have set hours they they you know take
royalties they pay commissions to the
business that they're dealing with so
this is not
um something unusual in Romania it
really is a legitimate thriving business
and they are trying to take this
legitimate business and criminalize it
in this particular scenario and I think
it's going to ultimately fail
well that you just that's a Playbook you
know that's the The Playbook is hey if
we uh uh just this question on what you
just said right the Curiosity so if it
wasn't illegitimate and it wasn't a
crime to go to jail can the government
suddenly create a law and get it passed
to be in then to get someone where
you're convicting them of a crime
because the laws have changed today
because that's what Giuliani did with
the mop and all of a sudden 240
something people went to jail on the
same day can they do that or that's not
something they can do
you can't enact I mean you could enact
legislation but it's on a moving forward
basis there's no in a criminal context
there typically is no retroactive
application so if something had you know
predated when the Law changes then you
can't go back and say something you did
because you know for a criminal charge
you need to have noticed that the
behavior is deemed to be criminal
conduct
got it okay well that's that's good to
know to see okay and last but not least
to wrap up to the audience so think
about the audience that's watching this
who doesn't like Andrew Tate and think
about the audience here that's watching
this that loves Andrew Tate and then
there's some that are in the middle like
I don't know I'm just trying to see
what's going on here is he guilty is he
not I'm just like some of the stuff he
says there's some stuff I don't agree
with but I'm more neutral similar to
politics Left Right middle right what
would you say to the people like what do
the people uh uh who think this is uh
somebody who is guilty what what should
they go look at like is there any
articles is there any things to follow
what what can they do because there are
a lot of people screaming off the top of
their lungs that these guys belonged in
jail for the rest of their lives and
there are those that are saying they
don't on the opposite side being very
supportive about it what do you say to
the people saying no these guys are
guilty they need to be done they need to
go jail and stay there forever
two points I want to make on that first
of all I think people need to focus not
on you know the content of their speech
whether they like or agree with what the
brothers are saying I think there's you
know some other critical things that you
need to think about which is the fact
that do we believe people should be
detained when they haven't even been
criminally charged is it right to keep
someone in jail for several months when
there is not enough evidence to charge
them at the time
um that's that's one thing second of all
do we want to start criminalizing speech
you know are we putting people in jail
trying to so that we can try to
reprogram them I mean that's not what
our justice system is supposed to be and
so we're trying to keep the system
accountable and that's not you don't put
someone away seize all their assets you
know try to get them to break so that
they come out and they don't say the
things they were previously saying and I
feel like that's something that seems to
be happening in this case because
there's you know a number of people who
don't or I should say a big uh portion
of people who don't agree with their
messaging but that's something that
should be addressed in a different way
not through the criminal justice system
that's not where you debate ideas and uh
it's it's not an appropriate use of the
system as far as what people could look
at or you know read to to learn more I
would just say that I I think a lot of
the things that Andrew says are taken
out of context I think
you know you'll always see that a one
little phrase that says massage
misogynist you know Andrew Tate believes
women are property and then if you
actually sit down and watch his
long-form interview he puts everything
in context and you know he says no I
believe women are equal I think when I
when I said that what I meant was you
know in a religious way the way somebody
gives you know the father gives away the
bride so you know he'll explain a lot of
what he means and I think it makes a lot
more sense when you hear his long format
interviews rather than just hearing you
know reading a headline or seeing one
little clip of something he said taken
out of context which I don't think
accurately reflects what his messaging
is and I think if you watch enough of
his content you realize that the
overwhelming majority of the things he
says is you know are things that I don't
think anybody
um disagrees with I think it's all meant
to be motivational and it's trying to
get young boys and men but it applies
equally also to women just to be the
best version of themselves and to work
hard and to live their best life and not
to be lazy and you know there's a lot of
positive messaging that people relate to
and I think it's a very small fraction
of the things he says that are
controversial
makes sense that was helpful Tina any
major dates uh to look at that's any
event any dates that are coming up or
nothing yet
so Monday is actually a big day Monday
we are um going to be in court again in
Romania for the appeal of the extension
of the detention order as to the tape
brothers so
the the lower court pretty much extended
it however that's that decision is being
appealed and that'll be heard on Monday
and we're hopeful that on appeal you
know it gets reversed and they are
released on house arrest as well
that's great that's great to know I know
many uh people are many of us are
following it very very closely Tina once
again thank you for uh taking the time
to coming out and giving us a bit of an
update on what's going on a lot of
people uh uh are are following this
closely and I can tell you if if
if there's anything they could have done
to make the uh Persona even bigger than
it already was they just did that
because it's going to be interesting
when when he does come out if the
allegations once everything is done
within uh uh if he is freed where he
lives how he changes his messaging how
much bigger he gets does he push back
more does he challenge more uh maybe
does he get on a spaceship with Elon
Musk go to a different planet and create
his content from there so the
jurisdictions are different who knows
what's going to be happening all I know
is I appreciate you giving your
perspective and ghs got a shout out
today that this is a very weird shout
out today for Glendale High School out
of all the high schools right it's it's
it's us and it's John Wayne just so you
know John Wayne went to our high school
as well so anyways Tina I hate that fun
fact yes thank you so much for your time
have a good one thank you Patrick it was
a pleasure talking to you likewise
right
right okay or we are
okay she's not there okay